dès que vous approchez des écoles
secondaires des affiches témoigne davis
populaire chez les jeunes interdit de
fumer de faire du skateboard les plus
récentes affiches interdit de vapoter
leva potage se représente presque
partout dans les toilettes surtout où
l'on doit même mettre des écriteaux pour
rappeler l'interdiction et même en
classe lorsque le professeur a le dos
tourné
mais voilà que la santé publique
confirme qu'un premier canadien est
atteint d'une maladie respiratoire grave
causée par le vapo taj l'adolescent de
la région de london en ontario n'avait
aucun historique de maladies pulmonaires
ni signes d'infection
le jeune s'est retrouvé aux soins
intensifs la semaine dernière mais il
est maintenant hors de danger
les autorités ne fournissent aucun autre
détail sur la maladie respiratoire ni
sur l'âge le sexe ou la ville du patient
pour des raisons de confidentialité
de quoi faire réfléchir au moment où le
nombre de vins potter augmente
rapidement d'un bout à l'autre du pays
notre génération fait c'est là la
génération cobaye pour la vap otage puis
qu'on va découvrir les effets néfastes
très bientôt suppose sans surprise que
ça mais c'est ça qu'il faut que les gens
réaliseront merck la clope pour
s'attaquer à ce problème de santé
publique la ministre ontarienne de la
santé a emboîté le pas à son homologue
de l'alberta et ordonné aux hôpitaux de
signaler tous les cas de maladies
pulmonaires reliés aux vapo taz
chiraquiens et catherine tasca ps
souhaite comprendre l'ampleur du
problème et développer des solutions
pour les jeunes ontariens je sais que
beaucoup de parents sont inquiets des
conséquences du bape otage sur la sens
leurs enfants dit elle mais il n'est pas
question pour le moment de l'interdire
complètement la ministre fédérale de la
santé se dit aussi inquiète mais il
ajoute qu interdire les cigarettes
électroniques n'est pas la solution
en raison des risques posés par le
marché noir réellement je pense qu'on
doit reconnaître était de bagnes ans est
jugée complètement va prendre at il
avait prêté à geci au canada le problème
de santé publique et mondiale les états
unis enquêtent sur 380 cas de maladies
pulmonaires relié au vha potage dont 6
décès puis l'inde le troisième plus
important producteur de tabac de la
planète a complètement banni aujourd'hui
même toute production importation et
vente de cigarettes électroniques ici
philippe leblanc radio canada toronto